the four in the number 5634
is blank times
blank then the four in the number 12
749 so let's think about what they're
saying so the four and the number 5634
that's literally in the ones place it
literally just represents four
now the four in the number twelve
thousand seven hundred forty nine that
four is in the tens place it represents
40.
so
this 4 represents 10 times
it's a 10 times smaller value than this
4. this only represents or this 4 i
should say this 4 right over here
represents 4 while this represents 40.
so it is 10 times
it is 10 times smaller than the 4 in the
in 12 749 4 by itself is 10 times
smaller than
40.
make sure i got the right answer let's
do another one
the number
3 779 264 or in the number 73 779
264 how many times less is the second
value of
is the value of the second seven than
the value of the first seven
how many times less is the value of the
second seven than the value of the first
seven so the second seven right over
here
that's in the ten thousands place it
literally represents seventy thousand
seven ten thousands or seventy thousand
while this represents seven hundred
thousands or seven hundred thousand
so the the seven on the second seven
is one tenth the value of the first
seven or another way of thinking it's
it's ten times less this is seventy
thousand and this is seven hundred
thousand so the value of the second
seven is ten times less than the value
of the first seven
let's do one more this is fun
fill in the following blanks to complete
the relationships between twenty five
thousand four hundred thirty and two
thousand five hundred and forty three
all right so twenty five thousand four
hundred thirty is ten times well it's
ten times larger
than two thousand five hundred and forty
three literally you take this you
multiply it by 10 you're going to get 25
430.
the digits in 25430
are one place
to the blank of the digits in the number
let's think about it here you have a two
in the thousands place here you have
that a two in the ten thousands place
here you have a two and a five in the
hundreds place here you have a five in
the thousands place and we could keep
going what we see is the corresponding
digit it is in this and 25 430 they are
one place to the left of the digits
right over here
now finally we're going to take 25 430
and divide it by 2543
well we already know that this the first
number is 10 times larger than this
number right over here so literally if
you were to divide the smaller number by
from or if you divide the smaller number
into the larger one you're going to get
10.
this is this right over here is 10 times
larger than this we said that was the
first part of the question
and we are done